getting ready in five four three two one
continuation I Love Lucy
yeah it is right is that right was I
Love Lucy ever put into a color yes so
it was like it started off and so the
last season was yeah it was the greatest
thing yeah it didn't get put into color
later it was just color hmm yeah I knew
that [ __ ] yeah it's so weird
people love Lucille Ball is supposed to
be
she's like iconic is help cuz I just
remember watching that show thinking it
was funny as [ __ ]
you thought it was funny I thought it
was super cuz I was super young and I
know they did a lot of physical comedy
on it so you know if I don't understand
what's going on as a kid if you're
throwing pies in somebody's face that's
just hilarious funny right even my mom
was laughing cuz she can't understand
English she has a similar she saw
lightly to get a PI interface that's
funny it's right yeah I mean every time
like someone says like who if you have
if you could buy anyone to a dinner dead
or alive who would you invite and I
always put Lucille Ball you put Lucille
Ball I would never expect you to put
Lucille Ball why you got three okay I'm
gonna ask you that question I know do it
you have three people then you need to
invite to a dinner that you can't invite
to a dinner huh who would those three
people be okay first one would be
Lucille Ball man okay
Lucille Ball weird but okay um I would
invite Malcolm X and you you you you
choosing those ones right now man you
try to get people to like you would not
invite Malcolm X okay go away I find
Lucille Ball Malcolm X who else and
Melissa McCarthy Melissa McCarthy
about Jenny McCarthy sister I'm sorry
cousin are they really related I think
they're actually related man
fact-check hold on let me look that [ __ ]
up real quick yeah let me raise the
camera even on right now right it is
right yeah flip that screen over to be
real quick uh yeah then it's just in
case I trying to [ __ ] up on this one
talk what was it you said Melissa
McCarthy yeah I guarantee you her and
Jenny McCarthy are related because Jenny
McCarthy is actually really funny she's
goofy yeah I think that runs in their
family may I just have a hot crush on
her when she was on singled out on MTV
remember that's five things you didn't
know about Melissa McCarthy's family
tree you uploaded and the number one is
general Karthi Melissa McCarthy let's
see this and the second is the car third
era Tibet I got this 56k modem internet
that is DN cut down dude yes it's true
that Melissa and Jenny McCarthy are
first cousins not even distant relatives
why aren't they like my own they gotten
down in the movie is Jenny McCarthy an
actress though I thought she was a model
and a personality personality I don't
think she ever went into acting though
per se I've never seen or anything else
besides singled out what the [ __ ] is
singing you are a single out we're like
a bunch of people in a crowd and like
randomly chosen and then you're like oh
no like the stage is a game board and
then you ask questions to the person
behind the wall single out you don't
member this I remember singled out I
remember uh do you remember the Cindy
Margolis show though Sina marquales
it came out like singer Cindy Margolis
was not a singer she was just bad ass
lady she was a blonde girl that was back
in the day when I used to like really
like white chicks but it was after MADtv
so MADtv was show and it's and then
missiny Margolis show will come out
after that late nineteen years late
jerkin I was absent I don't think I was
old enough round you about jerking at
the time but like I was I was I was
rubbing Ninja Turtles singled-out is a
dating game show which originally ran on
MTV see that's why I didn't
TV you name an TV nah man I didn't have
any cable or nothing huh I didn't have
any type of cable so when I was younger
everybody would talk about these cable
shows I would have to have the home he's
recorded on tape you know like a bootleg
black boxer my friends did so I would
have to go over and watch it there but I
didn't have it at my house though yeah
my family did believe in stealing father
was passionate I was stealing wasn't it
that's what that black box was she was
straight up stealing dude if I got
caught with that [ __ ] my dad would have
beat my [ __ ] ass man damn he has a
straightedge happy [ __ ] New Year by
the way happy new years right Happy New
Year Merry Christmas it all passed up
and kind of went by super fast man the
first week of January would you uh would
you do for New Year's New Year's I spent
some time with my girlfriend and her
family in Utah
look at that st. George oh so nice man
how many black people were there there
were none okay ask me how many tongue
and people were there they have a huge
talent comedian a huge tongue yo
actually you know what
he didn't Mormon tongue in population yo
I heard actually I didn't hear I
actually saw this on gangland I heard
there's a huge like tugging [ __ ]
community out in [ __ ] Utah in like
Utah that's like they they I guess it's
cause of that Mormon connect they moved
out there or something like that but I'm
not sure if it was Crips or Bloods or
whatever but it's some kind of huge
target gang community out there I don't
that again community but I don't have a
huge community for sure dude target
people make black people look small dude
they do tonging people are huge may all
look like freaking like if they did a if
tonging people did a 23andme
it would just be emboldened about
[Laughter]
great-great-uncle Mount Everest ago
that's huge man yeah with Tongan Samoan
and yes in Maori like no mo
Samoan Samoan and Tongan people dude
there's like there's no big a Samoan and
talking people dude they just have like
they're made to beat people's ass and
play football and play football yeah you
will see those [ __ ] Italian dudes on the
football team they completely look like
they have six kids but they're only 14
years old yeah
true man it's true they're so nice there
was a I think it was Christian Brothers
out in Sacramento they got in trouble
because I think they recruited a couple
of Tongan kids that were that were
recruited into their football team and I
think they got in trouble because they
weren't like 22 or so she's like like
impersonating a bunch of high schoolers
or some [ __ ] like that it might have
been Christian Brothers I'm not sure if
you go to that school but I think that's
what happened Oh Christian Brothers is a
school is a school is a private school
and they had that dope-ass football team
but for some reason I was thinking I'd
like to white Christian Brothers go to
school and they were like recruiting
people or some [ __ ] but a lot of high
schools do their shadow for sure dude
like Artesia high school like in
Lakewood Kyle for whatever like James
Hart and went there Malik story he'd
like were a powerhouse and then he
finally got caught and Scott Parish it
was like James Harden like 32 when he
won I think is 38 he is 38
you remember the the basketball player
that I [ __ ] with B most but he had the
worst [ __ ] career because I was
kneecaps oh yes right your boy you know
about it
and [ __ ] mother where is he he's a
coach now I think is he a coach yeah try
to come back but then his knees kept on
blowing yeah I heard it because one foot
was shorter than the other actually
that's true is it I heard it was it so
much that unevenness caused him to slam
on his knees really hard and blew out
his knees yeah man yeah yeah but dude in
college ball that dude was a force to be
reckoned with kimblue because he was the
first to be reckoned with that's why you
were so obsessed with them I love the
best how much he just dominated and
demolished and because I feel like
during that time to the the strong big
man was disappearing hmm and he was one
of those people to it he wasn't big
enough to be like a dominant dominant
center cuz he was a power for right was
he I think so a patient I don't think
using but he would just he would bully
his [ __ ] way and dude and I I [ __ ]
loved watching that dude play just kept
blowing out of [ __ ] and I thought it was
so weird that a 40 year old man was
still in college be like that man did
Greg Oden look like a dude that need
therapy he's just he just got that look
like he has Neanderthal dude he just got
that look man
yeah it looks like a nice ass dude it's
funny now because now the time has
passed he actually looks his age right
now he just looks his yeah but he's like
that since he was 18 years old yeah I
remember him playing basketball or seen
him play and the court next to us in Las
Vegas like that dude made everyone look
like his stepchild it was all bad I
wonder how big I can't even so he was
seven feet so he was a big man dude I
thought he was a little smaller he was
seven feet 272 pounds and he played a
senator
I thought he played power for cuz the
way he moved hmm he was quick yeah he
wants to be quick
oh man I [ __ ] love this dude man yo
shout-out to Greg Oden man I'll review
it for you
I was actually rooting for a lot of
centers at the time cuz I love centers
man who else was there
that [ __ ] dumbass kid from the Lakers
who Travis Knight no he got his career
ruined I think he was talking mad [ __ ]
to Jordan oh no no I'm not talking about
him I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry we're
talking about [ __ ] you yeah Andrew Bynum
and your buddy that broke his leg during
[ __ ] Disney bullying bullying god I
was a big bite of because I saw it when
him and Shaq went at it oh yeah right
that when him and Shaq were going back
and forth I was like that kids the
future yeah and right when I said that
his career yeah let's go bowling it's
filling himself his lips that's crazy
exactly hey b7v Tom ball I don't know
why he's balling in the first place what
the [ __ ] are you doing ball is seven
feet people don't Bowl now and what was
decided to pose about like that
seriously man [ __ ] a length of that
frickin stretch to get to the lane is
like but once that for them I'm not
trying to see no [ __ ] like 7-foot
person Bowl mm-hmm I told me get the
[ __ ] out it was a really good boy who
was Khalifa Wiz Khalifa he's an amazing
bowler amazing if you want to see
amazing bowler
why is he bull rappers bow him I don't
know I thought bowling was like an old
white person sport or like TV on ESPN it
looks like it yeah like a Korea turtle
when you go for yourself you know you
see them yeah yeah my damn I mean
rappers what the [ __ ] I didn't know
rappers bolt yeah man like him up he's
doing there's a Khalifa bowling Wiz
Khalifa him and his whole
Taylor Gang they got two pins in Studio
City what yeah every Wednesday night and
they Bowl yo first video that pops up
pins feet Taylor gay Dodie told you what
the [ __ ] of this fool does muy Thai
any balls yeah that was like yo Jabril
cuz this is really really my name is
Khalif oh [ __ ] you bowled yeah he's like
ha Turkey do they ha ha ha
Chevy Woods get this there you say
what's up to him is he really nice he's
super name you're actually really good
at that when you see a celebrity you're
actually not afraid to say hi I'm Matt I
don't know yeah some people and you
don't do it in a very obnoxious way you
just say hi you tell them you know you
[ __ ] with this [ __ ] yeah go about your
way I can't do it I get weirded [ __ ]
yeah well it was less something happen
to you Ania long that's right when I saw
the alum and I held a hand extra long I
did I was at Sundance and I saw near
long and I shook her hand I said I
masturbated to you so much of the kid
know I know but I definitely did
masturbate to Neela
Oh a hundred percent dude he longs bad
as [ __ ] she's still bad man
she's definitely bad yeah like I held
her head I did that to people I did that
to Tatiana Ali I announced at the knee
along who surprisingly looked like they
could be related yeah but I helped
Tatiana lose your hand
super [ __ ] long and I just didn't say
anything what was that this was that a
it was that a club event or some [ __ ]
like that
oh okay because she has like a Asian I
heard she for like Asian dudes or some
[ __ ] but she's friends with a couple of
my friends stereotypes stereotypes you
know I'm saying I'm saying like we
always do stuff but you know back before
yeah if you do something you to search
you know if you do a you to you see what
the stereotypes know but they're really
dope dudes and they're friends with
Tatiana Ali and uh John Street he
introduced me to John Connolly and all I
could think about was actually banks and
I just just that yeah yo you remember
when Tatyana Ali had a single oh yeah
danger
you do that [ __ ] hella fast dude remix
yeah man oh dude I can't I forgot the
second song on that single is Jairo she
was on a sailboat looking hella sexy
though I remember that the music video I
don't burn the music video
damn I'm going down memory lane now you
know buried in Tatiana Lida what if I
say the lyrics right now could you sing
it no all day long I think of you I
can't even think of things to do
wishing all of my day dreams come true
yeah no I can't
don't member it all I think it about but
down every night that's not that's not a
song what a Sunday Deering no baby
what the [ __ ] that's a different song
yeah that's what it sounds like ah yes
Africa our second single was she had a
second single yeah dude but Tatiana leet
was a [ __ ] though yeah I was thinking of
Maya uh yeah II masturbated to - you
know we're gonna have to wait for Cisco
to get off the stage to their music
video and it's just her and in like
Chinese robe the other leg was show out
like damn it's kind of weird when you
kind of jack off to the side he's
anything you see them in person and the
other person not gonna be more as an
adult I absolutely do urban this [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh what's it called uh Tyra
Banks we saw Tyra baby and barbecue yeah
I'm glad you said it cuz I did she was
she was my first night do you remember
the first time I was like I must have
been 12 11 12 13 that was your first
night yeah because I remember I had like
the college rule bound notebook and I
will cut pictures at our bank and glue
them into this notebook and just look at
and she had this one photo of her in a
pink bikini on the swimsuit edition I
know you don't remember this one of
course it was
that is fun and i splooged all right you
kids don't even know how [ __ ] lucky
you are do you have any idea it took for
us to masturbate the women we had this
[ __ ] I had the [ __ ] the
children's scissors but one that you
can't cut your skin all that Hannity
DOMA cut and he had to cut that [ __ ] out
and he was so ashamed of himself he
putted it into a notebook so it looks
like you study exactly that's exactly my
game plan and then he opened this [ __ ]
up and he whacked off to Tyra Banks and
a cut out of a notebook yeah that's how
hard it was you guys have been so lucky
you just go on Google right now you look
a pie recipe and a [ __ ] comes out the
foot shadows hazel eyes are beautiful so
what are you doing in Utah over the new
year Utah just like playing pickleball
hey [ __ ] is picking is [ __ ] fun dude
yeah what anyone says you could say you
could you could tell this to do as much
as you want he is the widest person I
ever met in my life I'm not gonna argue
that I'm not gonna argue that I've never
heard a pickle but I'm pretty sure it's
fun I just don't know what it is I just
found out that [ __ ] where you throw the
beanbag into the hole oh [ __ ] yeah if I
can't corn oh that's what they call you
in with white people do I mean if you
hang around you know sever leg long
enough they all have like these cornhole
shits in front of their cap I don't know
what the rules are but I do enjoy it
though I just throw that [ __ ] in there
yeah I just know if you like make it a
hole or you like knock them off or so
[ __ ] yeah
but I found my coops kube's was set
that's the game you say you like you and
Mary oh oh cool that's right idea I
didn't actually play it so wide as [ __ ]
that's a Viking game Vikings oh really
yeah
that's not why that's cultural bro
Viking is cold for you why would I say
white I mean white American I think
people get that confused when I say
white people we're talking about white
Americans if you're if you're European
if you're [ __ ] like in Sweden or
whatever I don't know anything about
that culture so when we see white we
talk about white Americans oh [ __ ] okay
cool
yeah that's cultural but Ezria culture
yeah yes it's called coops okay Oh BZ
yeah I don't actually get the plate I
just uh just uh I just taking photos of
it and you liked it I liked it look
really fun yeah
because I was too busy taking photos I
was like in my photo mode at the plant
again I was I was doing the whole
vacation thing taking photos I was into
editing and shooting so by the time I
was done taking photos everybody was
done playing Koons what football is fun
it's like tennis it's like that little
wool football a pickleball I mean what
the wiffle ball yeah and just these
fat-ass paddles like a low last net it's
fun what's the point of coops I mean
that coops was it called pickleball yeah
it's like Dennis pretty much like
exactly like tennis just with different
ball on a racket Oh what the [ __ ] yeah
but it's just more uh I mean it can't
get intense like they have like the top
rated players in Utah oh my god it
sounds ridiculous I know do they get
paid are they paid athletes yeah
yourself like you get sponsored if that
shit's in the Olympics I'm gonna be
pissed tonight okay shuffleboard yeah I
don't I don't understand the
Constitution do shuffleboard got super
popular me I didn't know about that
should have been Olympics because it
don't let the little hipster team a
little uh it was a was a Korea oh man
what's it oh I know where the
interference is coming from us from your
telephone bro whoops see that's what it
was err [ __ ] on the airplane so it
wasn't the laptop um yeah I remember the
girl shout like the big-ass glasses and
she was like the the the captain of that
was [ __ ] call shuffle board shuffle
shuffle no curling curling that's what
is called early yeah and she was like
you know coaching her to players doing
the [ __ ] scrubbing the ice
it just looked cool because she that she
looked like someone was trying to erase
their past trying to sort of like live
yeah to survive another day so but I
heard that the the when they do that it
slows it down so they're creating like
friction or something they ass so that
actually slows it down I thought it
would they were doing that to make it go
faster cuz they're gonna [ __ ] fast
[ __ ] cuz I thought they were heating it
up to make it more slick or some [ __ ]
but it actually slows it down or
something yeah yeah yeah currently so
you were you were you were you went to
Utah Utah or hiking went to Canary Falls
little stand what's those shits called
it's like the marble is that the thing
that everybody goes and takes pictures
up yeah yeah that thing I mean just
chillin read books man next to the pool
you know I got that man like honestly
like every time I see your Instagram
story so much this mother who don't read
but you really do yeah I shouldn't know
because I'm supposed to read too but I
never read how did you make it up time
do you keep reading a [ __ ] on my bro put
that [ __ ] off you reading his heart like
really the song gets hot I feel like
it's more difficult I feel like me I
just can't retain information like I
want it to like be in my bones so that I
can make sense of it and share it if it
means sense to me but it seems like
nothing makes sense to me I don't know
if I'm [ __ ] getting dementia or some
[ __ ] or just like some people get
enraptured into books and I think that's
the art part like a Harry Potter people
yeah I'm trying to get in raptured into
a book yeah and that's like I have two
books that I've been trying to read that
I know will help further my career I
haven't gotten past the first page save
the cat mmm something I'll rip it out
save the cat you know write still made
it happen I don't give a [ __ ] but I know
say the cat would help me you know
structure my ideas I'm bad at structure
so I'm very good at writing out ideas in
terms of like thought and I know what I
want in it but I don't know how to put
it into a story that makes sense you
know Dana like I know I want a
[ __ ] to die right other jokes
about a third act yeah yeah I don't know
how to make you flow where it kind of
translates over to an audience huh and
that's where books like say the cat will
come in I'm like laughing already and
crying cuz I want to know what your
second book is what is I don't know what
it is oh the the one I bought you that I
should have read with you the screen
right now is standard yeah I read like
three minutes is that not a 1984 some
[ __ ] no I did I used to it
I remember when Facebook just started
popping up and I think like the thing
that irritated me the most cause when I
was younger I should get irritated by
everything but there was this Derek I
knew for a fact it's got the dumbest
[ __ ] on earth right I know for a
fact this will cannot read like I [ __ ]
you not
I know he can't read and he put on his
Facebook he says current book I'm
reading mine cough yes
Hitler [ __ ] I was like bro and I was
like bro put that [ __ ] down you do not
read it I wrote that [ __ ] that's all
deleted it and he messaged me he was so
bad as I brought my you got [ __ ] call
me out on that [ __ ] bro
sounds like you know what Mayan comp is
dude alright yeah nah it's the first but
next to me duh that's just a testimony
to the the type of colorful people I
used to know
yeah yeah I mean yeah would you do for a
Christmas Christmas [ __ ] what I do a
Christmas oh I just went to my grandma's
house I went to my grandma's house she
passed away rusted piece grabbed my ass
and peas Big Mama
yeah just finalizing some stuff picking
up some furniture some dressers that I
still at the house before the buyers you
know the place drama
you know drama house drama you know
[ __ ] you know I go in a closet and I
find a stash of photos can't go there
well you know you know like you know a
little new tease from the 70s
oh god beauties from the 70s this is
doesn't make any sense and then there's
a picture of like you know some cousins
in that context that's kind of weird my
cousins are nudies in the 70s no no my
yeah my uncle my uncle just has some new
teas from the 70s and he has some kids
[ __ ] this is gone this is pictures of
his children Matt god dammit okay you
know what it is oh yeah you got there
there's like you know those pictures
nice cool pictures mixed in this is what
it is his uncle we're at pedophile
[Laughter]
laughing because it's funny and it's
awesome truth okay are you for yeah man
it is heat like I'll give a [ __ ] about
no like he's better holidays you wrecked
my family I don't give a [ __ ]
oh really okay cool well [ __ ] that guy
there look what's his name back she's
not a pedophile he's just because
there's so many degrees to what is it
when you become a sexual sex offender in
original it's a red dot guy yes
you know was it Madison Africa was
called the Suzy nod or something
Suzy does it's like when you get that
you put your like zip code in and you
see how those little pins pop up and
like you guess that red dot it's I
forgot what you're called
what's called um see if you guys look at
my Google search and [ __ ] you're gonna
be surprised because I only put in
keywords because what I'm gonna type in
right now to find this out is red dot
sag racist and it says rapist explain
themselves on reddit everybody got
reasons why they do stuff Oh sex
offender tracker app look out what it's
called though it's not madison.com oh
that's that mass in that commas when you
care like see if like you're what is
lover website to know where sex
offenders honor Megan Megan comm right
what is it
Megan's Law Dana sexy videos make wait
probably probably never great knows
what's up what they do raise are okay
why are people pass on this type of [ __ ]
like it's funny cuz with Google their
site the stuff that people yes I'm
wondering if somebody's asking this
question because they're scared for
their kids or is because they're the
rapist right can a level 3 sex offender
lives here school what is it what is it
Tier three sex offender and they're
gonna find agree Danny find out what
tier monocles in so tier three offense
includes any sex offense for which a
person has been convicted or an attempt
or conspiracy to commit such an offense
that involves one non parental
kidnapping of a minor a sexual act with
an with another by force or threat and
the I'm too lazy to click the rest yeah
my uncle's a tier 3 for sure oh he's
he's at tier 3 yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
man yeah
and is weird having that be a part of
your family like how do you deal with
that [ __ ]
these delete them out your life like you
don't even yeah cuz I don't really have
a relationship with them he was always
that uncle that would never attend fat
[ __ ] family gatherings like he was show
up after the fact when people were like
driving back onto the freeway to go home
you would see him like us just looking
like a scavenger in the desert and my
dad be like good good it's like you need
some money to you've got so and there's
like okay what the hell there's some
money and like all right cool and then
just drive off and then my dad's silent
and then you you know get older you're
like oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] dad like just
was looking up to his big bro you know
if he still has that real like that
always still in the front yeah try
talking into the [ __ ] there you go there
you go they try to put that [ __ ] I look
this way I can move this [ __ ] yeah there
you go yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah like this oh
cool
yeah so I mean he's pretty much the
leader but it's also affects me because
it affects my dad yeah so your dad has a
has a he's still the baby brother to him
yeah and so in that in that type of way
you can't he can't really shed the fact
that he looks up to him no matter how
much of a [ __ ] he is huh see that's so
interesting because I feel like that's
the thing that parents have with their
children mm-hmm right so no matter how
much that kid is a [ __ ] they always
say that's still my baby and they always
want to do right by this yeah for sure I
mean like just even recently you know I
found out I think I told you this that
my grandma had a kid before Charles oh
[ __ ] that his name out there whatever
[ __ ] love and that baby Africa it was
some crazy southern black name I feel
like like juniper or something like a
guy I think was a girl a girl yeah a
girl before her first living for
something like that yeah just a baby my
grandma went to go work dropped off the
baby the baby bit off and
go off the bottle and choked on the
nipple I thought you go save the baby
get off your grandma's nipples like
grandpa boy
and then you grab my bucket threw her in
a swamp with a bunch of alligators Oh No
maybe
Oakland Oakland so it was a nipple of
the bottle and it was about that the
baby choked on
and so having Charles was kind of like
her Redemption Redemption I'm not gonna
let go of this baby by any means because
God gifted me the opportunity to be a
mother
so that's chemo drug addict [ __ ] yeah
that dude relied heavily on my grandma
till his day and till she passed away
yeah geez the end to this day yeah
because he got caught you know went back
to jail because um what was it he forgot
to update his papers to notify where he
lives
okay my grandma was always updating for
him so she couldn't do this year oh so
when you're when you are a sex offender
you have to constantly let that era
where you go yeah apparently yeah
what papers and he wasn't doing that he
wasn't doing that apparently my husband
was doing that this whole time as an
adult
yeah he's like 68 65 she's like that
it's crazy Joel was your Brad mom when
she passed away hmm
one as an 81 year old she cost she was
doing everything yeah from 75 Evelyn I
know you know that's [ __ ] wild man
Debbie what in the world that's why I
don't care and so your your your dad
still he's still trying to garner a
relationship with him though yeah yeah
it's hard cuz like he's like you know he
gets out because he's actually getting
out next month and the house is not
gonna be there cuz you my uncle thought
that he was gonna get my grandma's house
but they're selling it yeah he is a what
am I gonna live it's like he's 68 yeah
thirty years ago we talked him up I say
he's so stuck in that mindset but he is
he you should get like Social Security a
[ __ ] though right maybe I don't know
have to become a sex offender
get them she's provoked I don't know I
don't know what that I don't like that
type of [ __ ] dude I know it sucks that I
have to kind of like I don't know man I
don't need to know yeah yeah I kind of
do because Magos a [ __ ] it's it's
weird cuz like I don't know I don't have
too many family here you know what I
mean I just got my older brother I have
a couple cousins one lives out in Jersey
and the other one lives out in San
Antonio Texas I believe and then at my
aunt and uncle and at it and everybody
else in Korea my mom's kind of like
cold-bloodedness [ __ ] so we got some
relatives out of Korea so like typically
with like Korean people if you go back
to Korea you have relatives there you
better make damn sure you say hi
you pay your respects you say hello this
is what my mom says I hate him right
like in Korean she translated I asked my
mom because I'm planning to go to Korea
next year I go yo do I have to go say hi
to all your elders she goes they haven't
called me in years they're [ __ ] dead
to me cold yo my mom's cold blooded his
[ __ ] she goes maybe the only people that
you should say hi to are like this
person than that person other than that
she goes just have fun is your vacation
tomorrow she's [ __ ] savages hell dude
that's high so that's how she's always
been man let's head it man so holidays
for you must be kind of like I must be a
[ __ ] addict that's a man had days
like I just don't I don't it's funny
like growing up and going to my
grandma's house and see my cousin my
uncles and all that [ __ ] and like know I
have a family like I know you guys yeah
but I don't know what's going on yeah
and then you become an adult and the
[ __ ] gets real and you're like this
family is a lie you're like yeah what I
don't want I don't know you guys like I
used to know you in a sex night now I'm
like trying to deal with believing that
I don't really have a family like yeah
that I thought I did
yeah before I said yeah that's weird to
look away you have a I mean I know your
mom if you guys don't know the backstory
to the khalif's thing as a police mom is
Vietnamese so he's half enemy's half
black and his mom was a refugee from the
Vietnam War and I came over here and
she's actually deaf so she doesn't have
any fan
you're absolutely not yeah no virtually
no family since she came out here 18
yeah she so she came out where she was
80 she wouldn't even be able to
recognize family if she had it still in
Vietnam actually not that's [ __ ] wild
yeah I know yeah so all the all the
family stuff that you're dealing with is
only with your father's side follows
that yeah that's why we're crazy and I
did it's a mad crazy it's like no
hallmark moments man there's no you know
I never actually actually this what do
you I
what do you identify more with being an
Asian American or black America weird uh
it's very weird man I can't really like
identify with either or or yeah so
you're kind of like in a nebulous
basement yeah I just see myself as
Khalif or whatever people call me that's
interesting because I feel like a most
most of the mixed homies that I know
that are half black they always identify
with the black side yeah well for sure
because I have my black family and they
teach me ruses they're taking me out to
like the market with the Keene parade
yeah take me out to like exhibits and
[ __ ] like but you have both though but I
have both yeah but I have as far as my
education like my dad is like you should
read uh you know or watch Apocalypse Now
or you watched a Vietnam war on PBS buy
my blood like he didn't really take the
time to really educate me
yeah and I just know yeah but your dad
speaks Vietnamese be so funny wild which
is bizarre yeah he's just anything for
the Nikki man she's like you're not
speaking Vietnamese you just do it a bit
to be back where you like to come to me
later my boy come talk to me
I'll be so funny like my dad he doesn't
have like that accent it's like because
I'm like my mom taught me in her death
tone the way of venom and then to me
he's like yeah if I spoke to Vietnamese
person they'd be like what the [ __ ] are
you saying like yeah if I say like I
wasn't but to say something I I said a
lot but really bad
you know Gong Li Wu might feel like
literally I'm saying kid goes home
tomorrow yeah all right well I'm trying
to say is I'm gonna I'll be home
tomorrow yeah you know I literally like
it's very block yeah yeah and it it full
if you know Phil is out to an entire
sentence with my mom yeah yeah so that
we have our own little special language
and [ __ ] oh because it's a mix of
enemies and her family was she's nice -
oh that's right fascinating I couldn't
hear a deaf person they're just like
it's tough yeah yeah so she taught me
that way and doesn't really serve me
that's interesting dude so you wouldn't
be able to understand venom ease when
somebody speaks because it's based on
what your mom knows yeah if you were to
pitch it down I might catch up few words
but your dad could speak and understand
regular video music hmm oh [ __ ] yeah did
you so do you still hear your dad speak
Vietnamese to your mom yeah but I'm
starting to think because he can't he he
doesn't practice it as much as he did
back then when I was younger like going
to Westminster and like having more
Vietnamese friends and finish a family
member or family friends like he's
constantly talking to my mom which is
very limited you don't to hear them talk
it's very just basic basic s look Oh
salmon it's not deep at all
yeah yeah that's so interest so he's
just selling he's starting to sound like
my mom Oh husband the beads are starting
to go to your voice right yeah holy [ __ ]
mmm what in the [ __ ] world man see
that's the thing that I feel like oh
that's a good thing you're an actor cuz
you're so many things to pull from yeah
kind of sucks but it's kind of like yes
yeah I mean you know when you're getting
these characters and [ __ ] like oh I
could like I could relate yeah and [ __ ]
but I'm just trying to make it relevant
for people to try to understand yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy man all
holidays are like that for you I went
back to a Sacramento like I always do
the interesting thing is every time I go
back to Sacramento I always sleep like
$14 fourteen fifteen dollars easy quite
authentic
you you would that took you there yeah
she was quiet dude yeah call this [ __ ]
it's quiet it's like that just at home
and like yeah you know the parents or
whatever cooking yep
like food on the tables on the table
worried about no breakfast yeah it's
nice man I think like this this is
actually the first time I went back to
Sacramento and I didn't fight with my
parents
oh [ __ ] I always fight with them and I
didn't fight with them about [ __ ] what'd
you fight about last time
oh we should like burnt our [ __ ] and
like you're looking for memories and
[ __ ] before again I can't remember but
journals and [ __ ] phone oh no I was
looking for uh my old clothes
right like oh my [ __ ] alright yeah
it's like it's like you know clothes
[ __ ] cuz you know we shoot a lot of
sketches now so yo this would be dope to
have like to throw back at her so I've
had like this retro [ __ ] and then my mom
was like oh I threw all that stuff away
just go casually bring up that you just
threw it away
and I specifically told her not to I
specifically told her don't touch my
stuff until I come back and I'll take it
and it was why'd you throw it away she
goes I save some stuff but what is what
does that response and how did you know
which ones which stuff to say I just do
it all the way she does that [ __ ] dude
she throws away everything that I care
about
that's she throws away everything that I
care about I remember going back once to
the house cuz I was looking for my old
like tech window stuff when I was a kid
and I went back and I saw my mom
literally taking it out of the garage at
throwing it into the dumpster and I was
like why are you throwing it away like
I'm a little kid I'm like why are you
throwing it away she goes you're not
gonna use it it's taking up space bow
trophies both throws away they don't
give a [ __ ] about memories dude it's
about utility right you know space I'll
be other than photos because my dad took
a lot of photos of us when we were kids
but you could tell who was the favorite
kid and who was it because my photo
album is like straight up like a stack
of papers like ten papers I think and
then my brother has like six photo books
of him just being a two-year-old Oh Mike
and then I got one [ __ ] easy
a little photo book that's ages from 1
to 10 it is like spread out
[ __ ] falling out all the photos
out-of-focus there's no plastic over it
it's like thrown in there and [ __ ] it's
like pictures of gobble gobble gobble
became a doctor we like him yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude he did it right do
you still have uh do you have a lot of
photos of your family nah man my dad
didn't he take any photos and not really
well didn't teach you how to read
I don't know if I exist man I don't know
I got here you better to care about you
really they care about your education
but he taught you how to play ball
though yeah you did yeah a semi-pro say
my friend that's right that's right
that's a crazy experience though just
being a semi-pro basketball player like
you were living the life I wanted to
live really I wanted to be a ballplayer
bisect my absolutely sucks I don't play
with good people didn't matter what kind
of ball like you just wanted a ball like
in a league and like be on a team and
like I wasn't good enough
like I just number one I play with a
bunch of ghetto ass people so half the
time we would carry the ball yeah we
tried to all this weird add one [ __ ] you
know also I was like 240 pounds that's
funny
yep I wanted to be like was it was any
like Cadillac I want to be like Cadillac
you know super bad oh that fat
[ __ ] do it I could do it too
that's the piece Cadillac USA is [ __ ]
did you did you ball with like um like a
white shirt like one of those like
practice jerseys on yeah and then like
goggles and like I did do all the
toggles I had to wear goggles because I
had like negative now just because my
vision was poor it wasn't just I'll try
to be dope but I mean I used to play
ball and I remember when the [ __ ]
headbands were dope as [ __ ] man yeah I
was like I need this cuz if I put a
headband out I'm uh I was synced like
these three had anything to do with
anything
did you ever wear a headband for like
school pictures no I don't think we were
allowed to oh [ __ ] yeah my school was
super strict about stuff like that I
think like anything that was considered
that was going to be like political
gang-related like you weren't allowed to
have go now I was considered
gang-related yeah I think my headbands
were a lot if I
correctly I'm not sure I might be wrong
though but I was I didn't do any of that
[ __ ] though
like I think if I did that I probably
get beat up yeah because I was a I was
pretty like I was just like a geeky ass
kid dude just super geeky just uh I
don't know if I kept to myself I was
always loud as [ __ ] but dweeby little
glasses I used to wear [ __ ] a baby
blue [ __ ] and what South Pole t-shirt
suggested yeah
damn I had a shot John [ __ ] dick ass
denim jeans we're all about that KP
pride no we didn't have that I don't
know that KP price yeah well I I listen
to like Korean music is [ __ ] better life
to part all is all about to pilot
another life I used to practice put it
up the Westside side without having to
touch my fingers what which mean that
touch your fingers cuz like before like
you see this right here
yeah like don't make these to touch
though I all started without a man
manually do that [ __ ] exactly no I had
to do it manually I would practice I
didn't know that was a thing I'll be
like this I'm like yo yo you ain't a
real tug unless you can without it cuz
what you doing practice in the beer [ __ ]
I'm like okay when you see your friends
later at school you'll throw it up
weenus yeah but I couldn't do it at the
time so I do this west coast East Coast
[ __ ] was real do it as a kid everybody
was about that dude yeah man people
don't know like it would it was all that
like Biggie and Tupac [ __ ] I remember
was big my parents to sell everything at
that so my parents own a beauty supply
store and like that was during the type
like chains were big like everybody had
a fake gold chain or chain or stud
earrings all that [ __ ] like so they
would have that my parents would also
sell pictures yeah you know you know
those get a less a swap opinion right
hell yeah you go east you like the
catalogs and [ __ ] yeah like it's in the
slideshow so I was 16 my parents would
sell that [ __ ] so hilarious they had a
POC they sell a bunch of POC [ __ ]
posters that would like lined up a gold
the gold frames
so I had a bunch of Pop posters on my
wall pocket my person know who the
[ __ ] gonna work
I just know that I would ask if I could
happen all right so they would have that
they would have Jordan whatever anything
that was popular at the time so I would
have Jordan puck all over my [ __ ]
wall and on the other side it was like
kpop AGoT and it was the girls though so
we have like groups like SES is Finkle
baby Vox so I would have their posters
all address yep and the other side I
have a bunch of Kendall last black D was
looking at him I think I'm trying to
[ __ ] him yeah that was that was that was
a weird time in my life though like I
think like during that time that was
like when you're trying to figure out
who you are mm-hmm and so you're just
trying to be a little bit of everybody
and I wasn't really ashamed of it either
like I was I was raised as a
korean-american I only spoke Korean in
the house but the outside influences
that I did have also seeped in so it was
just like I had to switch back and forth
yeah I think that became a issue for me
when I got older because people were
trying to make me choose who I had to be
utterly yeah right so they're like who
are you like yo you're not so you're not
black you can't speak like that yeah
which people don't even understand by
the way when you guys hear me speaking
obviously you have not grown up around
black people if you think that I speak
in like a quote-unquote hood black way
because I'm not I'm a [ __ ] square I
am a hundred percent I was square if
that means that you did not grow up in
an area where people spoke like this so
if you think that this is like a ghetto
way of speaking that you have not hung
around good you have not so that's why
you know how I speak is develop the way
it is is because change is a product of
your environment yeah it's just a little
mix of both you know and then as I got
older I try to get rid of it because it
wasn't very good at getting jobs you
know you can't come into a job as I go
with so homey yeah yeah it's ER yeah
yeah it's the you know the slang in this
little little uh lazy I guess yeah a
cabbie yeah you'd be sprite and very a
professional being professional as I
mean yeah you know I uh we uh
so recently we actually watched the film
called blind spotting and he's been
trying to get me to watch my yeah you
know say check out the
Murch oh you got the merch dude I didn't
know I had it on baby
Oh what do you see when you see I see I
see it I see a tree when you smart but
then I see the ladies about the kiss
each other I see I see
the lady on the right is a white lady
and the lady on the left is a 40 year
old Biddy's you burn recive bro yep
that's what I see doing yeah yeah and
they bite the kiss mm-hmm last one yeah
go ahead slide spotting though if you
guys haven't seen it it's an amazing
amazing film yeah like I'm surprised I
haven't seen it yet yep Barack Obama's
top ten baby look at that Barack Obama
do it Ruby ray hates the film now but
white spotting is really doe who's the
director oh Jesus man I don't know I
don't know about another Raphael right
who's the director for black spot yeah
Carlos Sandoval was like with it no but
did an amazing job and I think like
number one the acting was [ __ ] killer
though it amazing they really grabbed
the essence of the bay you know if
you're a Bay Area person you'll
completely understand this film you have
to yeah if you're anywhere from North
Cal Sacramento Bay Area in the valley
whatever you won't understand this film
specifically because for me when I watch
this film I don't want to spoil it for
you guys if you haven't seen it but how
I connected with it was cultural
identity it was it hit that note so hard
and it was it represented the very
unique exists is that the Bay Area has
specifically with black culture you know
that a lot of people don't understand
like if you guys watch that film you
will understand me a little bit better
and it won't seem so forward to you and
that was a film that I watched that I
was like yo where was this film at like
[ __ ] seven years seven to eight years
ago when I was just starting you to
where people didn't understand where I
came from people from Sacramento they
didn't question it people from the Bay
Area didn't question it right but
anybody outside of like California or
even sometimes in LA they just didn't
understand they're like why is it
person speaking like that they don't
understand because they think that asian
person should stay in their Lane yeah
this is the lay that you stayed right
you're supposed to be that bookworm
you're supposed to be this dude that
speaks a certain way and it just never
saw an Asian person like that I mean
there was a lot of people that were
doing it already and they were getting
flack for it like Tim hi Tim back in the
day when he was starting up his YouTube
like he used to get crazy flag [ __ ] yes
I yo who are you like at the time
cultural appropriation wasn't the big
term but that's basically what they were
saying right because he's Timothy
DeLaGhetto from Fresh Prince of bel-air
you know why you got Jack and I mean
yeah but I I absolutely love that film
it was it was probably one of the better
films I've seen next to Guk pretty good
yeah
would you like about the film and I
loved just the way attacked race and
attacked identification yeah that's just
something but you know you hear just new
thing like hipster and your breakdowns
and like for acting and just like you
know what that means like you're not
hipsters like bleeding over to being
like the Silicon Valley like tech guys
that gets like it's constantly in flux
and it's weird and just you know being
black and like finding my identity just
me being a chameleon yeah like I'm in
you know going to my house next to
Roscoe's chicken and waffles and you're
gonna like yeah so Ben Oh Kent like a
Snoop Dogg gonna come over and like I'm
like what the [ __ ] am i doing right now
let's try to blend in and then go back
here to you know Long Beach or Lakewood
I go to you know Whitney high school
right all of my best friends are Korean
it's like 90% Asian yeah like I'm the
hookin ya know but I'm not the like it
was looking like I'm just like oh he's
like the black guy like yeah yeah yeah
I'm not the it's such a weird gray area
that I find myself
subconsciously doing yeah that thing is
just like I mean I I tend to do that too
though like straight up but when I go
back to Sacramento the slang comes out
big and right I think it's just cuz
that's what I grew up and I was really
comfortable with that
uh you know when I started going to
college I think a lot of people made me
feel ashamed of maybe not so much they
were trying to do it on purpose I don't
I don't really blame them for that but
it wasn't something that they were used
to and they made me feel uncomfortable
for it like they made me feel
uncomfortable being myself right so if I
if I use slang it just been you know it
was a little weird you know what I mean
and the great thing that film did for me
especially when I watched it was it kind
of like you don't really know especially
in America if you're if you're not
American what it is to be a black male
or female in this country and what I saw
that was there was a very specific scene
in there where there was jealousy on one
person's part because he grew up as a
white dude in East Oakland very hood ass
area you know yeah area whatever and he
was envious of him because he goes yo
you get to be that hood dude and nobody
questions your [ __ ] street cred but
because I'm a white boy and this place
is becoming a a tech industry where a
lot of a lot of white dudes are front
like they you know like destroying his
homes
yes destroying these homes or should
they think I'm a part of them but I grew
up just like you yeah but the flip of
that is the funny thing is I'm the
straight dude
but because I'm a black man right cops
are out looking for me right you know
but they're not looking for you and
you're the one with the gun you're the
one with everything but when they watch
look at you they just see a regular
white dude but I'm the guy that's not
causing trouble but they expect to see
the gun on me they expect to see the
mischief in me and so it was like two
people that didn't really understand
each other situation and it was it was
at me all right at me and kind of like
yo you don't know what it's like to be
me and we're both saying it to each
other they could have seen that story
yeah and it was it was fascinating cuz I
I feel like that's a film that a lot of
people should watch if they want they
don't understand that situation yeah
totally you don't tell me yeah I think
it's a it's a required or watch man
sorry education was just an yeah it's
fun to is super funny the the like it's
visually it's amazing too super symbolic
meta
I probably want about top 10 films a
long time now
oh [ __ ] hit me it hit me really hard
yeah you know it remind me to when I was
uh I was telling you this earlier when I
was in Sacramento if you guys go all by
Instagram there's a picture of me and my
best friend Gobbo
but you guys have seen in old videos
gobble now is you know I think he's in
his last year of his residency and he's
gonna be a full-fledged family nokton
right super proud of that boy that's my
best friend toto and in that in that it
was like a family photo right so it was
me it was get a go and it was the hero
and oh sure blob like Edwin so in that
in that photo you have me with four
black males right and that's if you look
at some of the comments that's all
people saw they saw be four black males
when I took that photo
I took that photo saying you know this
is my family right and I took that photo
thinking I'm super proud of these dudes
right right so I just met everyone but
Edwin is on his path to becoming a
neurosurgeon and [ __ ] amazing dude I
just met this guy but that's like Gobles
boy I met him super cool dude a [ __ ]
neurosurgeon I see my best friend who
grew up in the same situation as me
didn't grow up with a lot of money
albeit we did grow in the best parts of
Sacramento South Sacramento and he's
becoming a family doctor right amazing
and we have [ __ ] get a go and we also
have the hero right there there there
mom is actually the ambassador for
Rwanda you don't I mean and I'm looking
at this photo super proud and there was
a comment and mind you I'm not knocking
this do for writing this stuff but it's
a reflection of how people see black
males in this country and it didn't
really hit me until I saw that photo
because what he wrote as a joke and like
I said dude like I completely get what
you're coming from I'm not really
[ __ ] on you but he wrote oh it's
just a picture for David to post his
street cred I was like street cred what
are you [ __ ] talking about I say oh
it's because you looked at four black
dudes and me and you thought I was using
that as a vice to say oh I'm part of the
hood when the funny thing was the the
the purpose of this photo was I'm proud
of this like this this were from
Sacramento and we
like look at us it wasn't a nice bar
none of us are dressed we don't got like
grills in our mouth or some [ __ ]
we're not like posing or nothing it's
all smiling with dress nice and we're
just standing there and a lot of people
would like or and that comment kind of
like it hit a note in my head that is so
crazy because yeah I'm [ __ ]
it's like no chains no gold grills no
nothing is this literally skin color
yeah it was skin color and that's what
he saw and it was like that's your
street cred photo I was and I wrote back
I was like once a family doctor and the
other ones a neurosurgeon so no you know
right and it was disappointing only
because like I feel like in this
generation like if if somebody says
something like that about using Asian
dude if somebody said that about
somebody who was Asian
you probably be up in arms about it mmm
you know and this and it also goes on to
another level well people talk about
sometimes how Asian Americans have a
little bit of apathy when it comes to
color situations they choose when they
can and can't be a part of something and
that was I agree and disagree with that
sometimes but whoever that person was
that's what they're talking about right
there
hmm yeah it's like Europe Europe you say
a person of color when it when it
benefits you but you just said the white
race is common right right there and
that [ __ ] blew my mind man I was like oh
[ __ ] because I when I heard that I
didn't get I used to making it upset
about that what are these people talking
about what are people talking about and
that's what they're talking about
that's right you could say that that
that racially insensitive comment and
it's cool because you're Asian or a
person of color when you choose to be
and that's what that was and like I said
I'm not [ __ ] on you dude I'm pretty
sure you just you know said it because
that was the thing to do or whatever but
it was a hot moment for me you know
right yeah yeah yeah you just probably
seen that happen so many more times
before that yeah you know I just didn't
know it until now just people say they
want to be quote cuz like okay was good
deep in it yeah like I see what how do
you want to get about this woke miss and
then he says situation or you see like
the Selective mists of it are not really
treat understanding this yeah you know
just like really getting to know the
person like why would you say that in
the first place
I say that yeah I mean you know do you
want and I know us on social media like
a lot of people want to be the first
person to mention something yeah and
make it hot yeah yeah tons of people to
like it yeah you know so it would be the
first common to pop up you know it's
just you want to say something that's
the first thing you want to say is like
oh this is how he's a street cred yeah
and because what are you trying to get
out of that because it was a comments
that make sense like you know David's
invite to the cookout like that's that's
that make sense you know I mean when he
says street cred I was like yeah that's
not it man that's not it and it kind of
like made me feel bad about the photo
because the photo was to show how proud
I am of us as people and I think like
that's the blessing that I had growing
up a second kind of Sacramento
California and how diverse it was
because yeah yeah we all see color we
can't deny that [ __ ] I see [ __ ] color
all the time you know what I mean and
that's a beautiful thing I don't think
that's a bad thing it's just how we deal
with it and how we choose to treat
people when you see that color is a
different story
I love people's different cultures and I
don't want people to mesh completely
like that because I want people to have
their individual identities you know you
could be celebrated for it and that's
what I like
but Sacramento does that really well and
I kind of realized that you know if that
person's now from California maybe
that's why you said it but it did I'm
not sure if it was offensive it was very
disappointing mm-hmm that's what it was
you know you're blaming the guy for it
is really more like how I wonder what
you saw in that photo that made you say
Street besides that there was four black
dudes and that's that mean I'm being
crude about it but that's really what it
is you saw four black dudes and you said
all this to trying to I guess this is a
street cred photo but what about that
photo was like that right and that's all
I could think okay just be a photo yeah
it's one of those things man cuz I feel
like for you to just because you're
people look at you with that they're
just gonna say that you're black you
know it's funny I it's funny when people
was like yeah you're black [ __ ] really
well you guys yeah what do you guys like
yeah I can totally tell by your hair
right oh okay okay but when I see myself
I don't even I don't see Asian I don't
see black I just don't see anything so
I'm just but what I I'm I get surprised
when people tell me like oh yeah I know
you're black you're like this away you
are huh
what how am I like what what does that
mean because yeah umbrellas so yeah you
know like going back to like family like
being black and trying to be a chameleon
to hang out with my cousin in LA well my
cousins from my land to come out they're
like oh you should come down to Atlanta
and you know we'll cook you some real
foods like Oh get down with that yeah
what you know about was like [ __ ] I'll
get down with like you know [ __ ] pig
feet yes you know pig feet is like I
think it's a different layer black yeah
it's like okay now I gotta be that kind
of black like yeah why can't it just be
this but you'll see some [ __ ] to like
we'll be hanging out right and then
let's say we're at the gym is some [ __ ]
right and some dude will come up to you
like yeah what's up how you doing man
whatever and they tell me how you doing
switch it up real quick Pootie Tang yeah
boy like put it in well Pootie Tang was
talking to you dig was crazy you know
they just do it at the gym he looked he
just look like good lord
that was yo but the way he was talking
to you and the way he would talk to me
was way different was way different
cause he had that you know what it's
like wow Lavelle Obama thing yeah like
him going through the White House and
like yeah it's that kids get high hey
yeah yeah yeah it's like yeah Mario's is
that to about me when a she
so is that bother me it doesn't bother
me because she's right like she sees
that in me where she goes you know the
way you speak to white people are the
way you speak to like black people makes
people are way different
yeah I said what do you mean and she was
like well when you speak to a white
person you're very you're not as
colorful you know she's like you don't
have as much energy yella just very
you're very vanilla like yes thank you
very much thank you do psych so at her
and her apartment complex the the gate
people they will let you win
I figure majority of our black women
right and I grew up in AB you supply
store so that's my realm yeah we got
like I've
grew up talking a black with my whole
life you know if anything else I don't
have a black males accent I have a black
females accent that's my [ __ ] you know
they be sought you know I come in and
you know whatever I know you doing how
you doing that you look real good
whatever topping it up and she noticed
that as she goes how can you talk like
that around them what do you mean
and I didn't catch myself doing it but
it's just that's the realm and I'm used
to comfortable because I
grew up in a black beauty supply store
80% of that clientele with black women
you know that so that's that's how I
connected that's how we speak we chop it
up we have a good time and yeah I got I
catch myself doing that all the time too
though you know you kind of go you kind
of go to what you used to connect yeah
it's early I mean you see that way you
said that you know you see the nails you
know like I know this kind of hurt yeah
I know this I know yeah we were at UH so
I went to her a holiday party same [ __ ]
see a white people I found one black
dude talk to him online dr. Bombay I
feel comfortable he was cool we could
just chop it up whatever and it was it
was easy cuz that was just the America's
you're going to POC is there probably
too I mean there was those Asian people
and stuff too but they were not the
Asian people that I grew up with they
were like Asian technique you know which
they're really cool too I like my super
nice people okay no we don't connect
yeah they don't they don't have that
that that stank that I that I'm used to
yeah you know yeah is they all serious
yeah yes Alice serious 800 pressing
people yeah it was kind of random but
the barrier was like she was said to she
goes of course the one black person
beautified anyone connect with him the
most right you know and I was like he
was just easy to talk to
yeah yes yeah totally a big man Baba was
like he goes the one person that you
will feel you will place me with what
black man what I'm used to man it's my
comfort zone yeah then it's create a
series around yeah so that's serious
well you guys we're gonna wrap this [ __ ]
up uh yeah so uh you can find Kelly Boyd
at a Instagram on the instagrams that
Khalif Boyd that's it and you'll see him
all movies you the actor you don't see a
bit a lot of [ __ ] yeah man 29 year 2019
that's a yeah I'm feeling fine 2009
that's right it sounds like a [ __ ]
like high school will close you from
2005 all right